buongiorno
tutti oggi non vi parlo di treni vi
parlerò di come arriveremo nel 2039
viaggiando come viaggeremo non vi parlo
di treno di metropolitana e che però ci
saranno nel 2039 2039
se andrà ancora con l'alta velocità da
roma a milano nella metropolitana di
tokyo ci sarà una situazione analoga a
quella di oggi ma insieme il re il treno
e la reggina la metropolitana della
mobilità fanno 10 per cento a mobilitare
pianeta tutto il resto oggi è trasporto
su gomma ed è quello che veramente sta
cambiando allora vediamo in questo
nostro viaggio chi si muoverà nel 2050
2039 saranno pochi meno 9 miliardi e
mezzo di persone di cui un paio di
miliardi scarsi over 60 ne abbiamo
sentito parlare prima e soprattutto
questa grande crescita demografica sarà
in paesi come l'africa più di un
miliardo di persone che oggi sono
completamente destrutturata dal punto di
vista della mobilità e quindi avranno
bisogno di grandi investimenti in
infrastrutture non solo ferrovie strade
porti aeroporti e quant'altro e dove ci
muoveremo ci muoveremo nelle città
perché nel 1900 solo due persone su
dieci vivevano nelle città oggi siamo 5
su 10 nel 2039 saremmo quasi 7 su 10
il che vuol dire che la mobilità sarà
nelle città o tra le città veloci
spostamenti tra le metropoli e grosso
dello spostamento all'interno delle
metropoli e come ci muoveremo dovremo
muoverci in maniera sostenibile perché
perché il cambiamento climatico è uno
dei grandi problemi del nostro sviluppo
più un grado di temperatura dal 1880
sapete che il problema enorme
286 miliardi di tonnellate di ghiaccio
che si sciolgono ogni anno il risultato
di questa operazione è che i mari stanno
salendo di 3,4 millimetri all'anno e non
c'è ragione di pensare che questo trend
si fermi abbiamo visto venezia in questi
giorni sott'acqua ma ci troveremo con i
mari che possono salire fino a 53 58
metri nei prossimi anni
bene e il il settore dei trasporti oggi
è uno dei settori peggiori è uno dei
settori che continua a consumare sempre
più energia fossile in questo grafico
vedete dal 73 al 2015 il numero di
tonnellate di energia fossile utilizzata
dal settore trasporti è raddoppiato
vedete che gas naturale una piccola
cifra è quello giallo è l'energia
elettrica che è sempre stata appunto
treni metropolitane negli ultimi anni
cresce un po perché sta arrivando la
mobilità elettrica di cui parleremo dopo
è il terzo peggior settore solo la
mobilità oggi produce il 25 per cento
della co2 del pianeta pensate un solo
settore che riesce avere un impatto così
importante bene allora a questo punto
vediamo quali sono i 30 della mobilità e
proviamo a fare questo viaggio nel
futuro
bene la mobilità condivisa la mobilità
condivisa è uno dei fenomeni della
schering economy la sharing economy sta
impattando pian piano tutti i settori è
nata dall'hosting tutti conoscete anzi
sicuramente utilizzati abiendi e
ed è un settore importantissimo perché
la sharing economy è sostenibile per
definizione perché si utilizzano meglio
le risorse che ci sono e la chery mobili
t questi sono dati in italia sta
continuando a crescere ed è molto
importante
probabilmente a trento sarà ancora da
sviluppare ma se andate nelle grandi
città come milano roma firenze bologna
trovate già un trend di crescita molto
importante quindi cambiamento di
comportamenti delle persone che nella
sharing economy incominciano a
utilizzare tutti gli strumenti che sono
a disposizione tra cui la mobilità
seconda cosa internet of things di cui
si è parlato anche prima internet oscars
questo è molto importante quindi a
questo cambiamento di comportamento a
cui la gente è disponibile ad andare
occorre una tecnologia che l'abilità
quindi oggi ci sono già le automobili in
grado di uscire da solo dal garage
mettersi in strada dialogare con gli
altri mezzi modo ad aumentare in maniera
significativa alla sicurezza e
fondamentalmente i dispositivi
tecnologici sensori e telecamere e
sistemi radar che sono ormai
estremamente chip e quindi si possono
montare all'interno di tutte le
automobili trasformeranno completamente
il modo di viaggiare e il modo di
relazionarsi tra di loro dei mezzi che
oggi frequentano la strada quindi un
intersezione tra un passaggio a livello
di un treno e un autobus una macchina
come queste saranno domani gestiti in
maniera predittiva
e arriviamo la guida autonoma quando
penso alla guida autonoma
penso a questa relazione biunivoca
sempre stata nel novecento tra
l'automobile e il suo proprietario non
se ci pensate veramente una prigionia
reciproca
quindi se penso all'auto tono ma penso
si all'auto che diventa autonoma cioè
che diventa autonoma anche dal suo
proprietario guidatore ed è molto
importante
chi sta investendo sulla guida autonoma
ma non solo e forse non più non
maggiormente i grandi player dell'auto
motiv come potete immaginare ma stanno
investendo per esempio i grandi player
della digitalizzazione come google o
apple oppure un soggetto 37 miliardi
notizia di poche settimane fa da parte
di amazon facilmente intuibile perché
per portare i propri pacchetti con
dispositivi di guido tono ma avete
sentito parlare dei droni che ci
porteranno i pacchetti sui terrazzi ma
37 miliardi di investimenti sono la
realtà
bene tutti stimano che nel 2039 lo
vedete avremo nel caso più ottimistico
un bello 80 per cento i veicoli con
guida autonoma ma anche le stime più
pessimistiche ci dicono che saremmo
ormai oltre al 30 40 per cento e il
trend comunque sarà tutto di veicoli
autonomi
ovviamente si apre un dilemma etico
enorme che direi che è propedeutico cioè
riuscire ad avere veramente
un'automobile che si muove da sola senza
il conducente richiede di risolvere
questo problema
quando oggi noi guidiamo la nostra
vettura ci troviamo una condizione della
macchia nera che vedete nel video e un
camion davanti a noi per del carico che
cosa succede noi abbiamo
una reazione che non siamo assolutamente
in grado di prevedere a priori e o
andiamo contro il carico se non siamo in
grado di reagire in maniera diversa
oppure proviamo a buttarci a destra dove
incidentalmente c'è un povero
motociclista che in questo caso non si
salverebbe oppure proviamo a buttarci a
sinistra in ogni caso abbiamo una
reazione che cos'è che succederà nel
momento in cui ci sarà invece la guida
autonoma
succederà che a questa reazione si
sostituirà una decisione perché sarà
successo che a questo punto un
programmatore dei programmatori quelli
che stanno programmando la guida
autonoma avranno immaginato tutte queste
circostanze e avranno deciso avranno
deciso che cosa fare in situazioni di
questo genere cioè avranno deciso quale
sarà il male minore
potete immaginarvi che razza di problema
etico gigantesco che si pone provate a
immaginarvi se dietro una curva
viaggiando sull'auto più sicura del
pianeta che avete comprato proprio per
essere tranquilli vi trovate una
scolaresca che attraversa fuori dalle
strisce pedonali e l'auto deve decidere
se buttarsi nel dirupo facendo morire
quello che si è comprato l'auto più
sicura il pianeta oppure stirare una
ventina di bambini che sicuramente si
stanno comportando in maniera sbagliata
questo dilemma etico richiede che i
filosofi lavorino insieme all'ingegnere
in questa fase importantissima di
progettazione ed è quello che sta
avvenendo
certamente la guida autonoma avrà dei
vantaggi enormi per esempio le auto in
vita autonoma
non hanno bisogno di semaforizzazione no
immaginate i nostri semafori che cosa
succede ad oggi e le auto in vita
autonoma sono in grado di fluidificare
il traffico maniera enorme
il grosso delle automobili in giro per
il mondo si muovono una velocità
commerciale si chiama così bassissima e
quindi questo consentirà lo godremo dopo
di ridurre in maniera importante il
numero di auto circolanti questo in
realtà è già realtà in alcune situazioni
voi penserete ma dove nella silicon
valley no in etiopia in etiopia
abbiamo già dei comportamenti molto
simili vedete ovviamente sto scherzando
però questo lo dico per dare un po di
fiducia al fatto che prima che un robot
riesca a comportarsi come notista di
addis abeba dove effettivamente non
hanno i semafori
di napoli dove li hanno ma come sapete
non li utilizzano voglio dire ce ne
vorrà quindi prima di arrivare alla
guida 8 anno ma probabilmente dovremo
passare parecchio tempo
che cosa succederà a questo punto
succederà che si ridurranno in maniera
importantissima le flotte questo è molto
importante questo è uno studio delle
menti di boston che ci fa vedere
manhattan manhattan è una città dove già
viaggiano ogni giorno 275 mila
automobili e 13.000 taxi questa qui è
una immagine di manhattan la sera cosa
hanno fatto quelle della mta hanno
provato a simulare che tutte queste 275
mila auto siano a guida autonoma e
quindi si comportino in maniera
intelligente
oggi un taxi a new york per il 50 per
cento il suo tempo sta fermo e quindi
hanno provato a stimare quante numero di
veicoli che serve per dare lo stesso
livello di servizio a new york rispetto
alla mobilità attuale il risultato devo
dire di questo screening modelli
matematici molto interessanti è molto
interessante perché salta fuori che si
riesce a fare lo stesso servizio con il
60 per cento dei taxi e con il 50 per
cento delle vetture
insomma direi che
si cresce a 9 miliardi e mezzo di
persone la mobilità cresce però i
livelli di ottimizzazione possono essere
molto importanti
bene a questo punto quindi abbiamo
parlato di cambio di comportamenti
sharing economy abbiamo parlato della
tecnologia a bordo le auto che diventano
autonome a questo punto facciamo le
diventare anche green veicoli elettrici
cosa sta succedendo 2018 circa 2 per
cento dei veicoli elettrici dei veicoli
delle automobili circa 80 milioni di
automobili vendute in giro per il mondo
sono state elettriche perché così può
che vi chiederete ma perché se vado in
una concessionaria della renault o della
peugeot o comprare un'auto elettrica
volkswagen costa il doppio il triplo di
quello che è logico no un'auto elettrica
a un motore che come colora la lavatrice
di casa cioè voglio dire ma perché deve
costa così tanto rispetto alla
complessità enorme di un veicolo termico
non ha senso
ecco la risposta purtroppo la vediamo
nella slide successiva questa è una
suggestione per dire che ha meno
un'azienda ci sta provando come sapete
tutti alla tesla veramente va la
conoscono oggi nell'intero pianeta
vedete che sotto 1907 1916 c'è la
progressione che ha avuto la forti
la prima auto di massa che è passata in
quei nove anni da zero 500mila veicoli
venduti ed è la stessa progressione che
sta avendo in questo momento la tesla ma
qual è il problema
il problema è che i cinesi sono stati
piuttosto svegli e si sono lo vediamo in
questa slide accaparrati tutto il
cobalto che c'è in giro per il pianeta
quindi rete va bene chi se ne frega il
co button o il cobalto le batterie si
chiamano al litio dirige ce n'è un sacco
in giro per il mondo ma cobalto se n'è
pochissimo è il cobalto serve per la
nodo senza cobalto non si fanno le
batterie il comando lo vedete nella
prima riga la parte gialla
negli altri paesi non è in cina per
esempio in africa
solo che cinesi sono riusciti a chiudere
accordi commerciali e tutto il cobalto
la seconda linea che vedete che viene
minato cioè nel senso che viene oscurata
e lavorato a loro quindi hanno
fondamentalmente la golden share di
tutta la produzione di batterie del
pianeta quindi che cosa succede succede
che nel momento in cui si decide di
passare alle auto elettriche per capire
di cosa stiamo parlando se qualcuno sa
cos'è la giga factory della tesla in
nevada con una fabbrica di quel genere
si producono 300 mila auto per cambiare
tutte le auto elettriche servono 240
fabbriche di quel tipo e quindi stanno
tutti lavorando per trovare delle
tecnologie alternative al cobalto e
all'iter per risolvere questo problema
fino a quel momento probabilmente di
auto elettriche ne vedremo molto poche
perché continueranno a tenere prezzi
posizionati molto alti
in attesa di avere l'approvvigionamento
delle batterie
diciamo in maniera sicura e a costi
abbordabili
andiamo alle infrastrutture innovative
writer loop l'aper loop è un aggeggio
abbastanza divertente viaggia con un
motore lineare è stato applicato nel
mondo dei trasporti
già nel 1989 in una metropolitana
berlino quindi non è già più una novità
assoluta viaggio in un tubo è molto più
facile stare in un tubo che stare
all'aperto
non è il rischio dei greggi di pecore
che ogni tanto attraversano la firenze
roma e e viaggi poi viaggiare a bassa
pressione consumando molta meno energia
dai per luca è un aggeggio che nel 2039
noi utilizzeremo non ho minimo dubbio
negli stati uniti o nelle grandi
periferie della cina della russia e
quant'altro per fare 2.000 chilometri
invece che salire in aereo 10.000 metri
consumando una quantità di energia e
norme poi spostarci di 2.000 chilometri
può scendere gli altri 10.000 metri
probabilmente utilizzeremo uno strumento
di questo genere che ha un livello di
velocità e una tipologia di confort
molto simile a quello di un aeroplano e
la mobilità sul e non è solo passeggeri
ma è anche merci e oggi in giro per il
mondo il 90 per cento delle merci si
muovono su gomma anche perché abbiamo
circa il 95 per cento di strade rispetto
al 5 per cento di ferrovie non possiamo
costruire ferrovia lungo ovunque
l'obiettivo e decarbonizzare quindi come
abbiamo fatto con i tram con i filobus
quello che faremo nel 2020 e 39 sarà
viaggiare con camion in elettrico
che sulle principali autostrade
americane europee e cinesi o africana e
viaggeranno semplicemente ne rete di
qualche p con tecnologia assolutamente
note e consolidate mentre nelle nostre
città non avremo più problemi di
autonomia e di enormi batterie perché
viaggeremo su delle strade o induzione
che come oggi ricarichiamo il telefonino
chi lo fa con una piastrina induzione
già oggi già oggi e quindi immaginatevi
nel 2039 è possibile ricaricare le
automobili in questo modo mentre
viaggiano bene ultimo macro trend è il
tema della smart digitali mobility
solutions quindi quella che viene
chiamata mobility services io sul mio
telefonino o lo contatta l'altro giorno
ho 34 up certo giro in città magari
anche un po complesse però chiunque di
voi prova a guardare quante apa sul
telefonino che riguarda la mobilità con
una coda abbastanza spaventoso
l'obiettivo sarà integrale come è
successo quindi piattaforme metà
piattaforme come è successo anche in
altri settori
e alla fine c'è un un fenomeno che viene
chiamato dai tecnici mobility and
services e torniamo quindi al punto
iniziale il comportamento la gente è
disponibile averla sharing economy in
generale è disponibile incominciare a
concepire la mobilità con un servizio e
quindi la domanda che ci poniamo tutti è
ma nel 2039 avremo ancora l'automobile
di proprietà oppure sarà un servizio
alla mobilità ma proverei a rispondervi
con questo semplice video che penso che
possa togliere dubbi anche i più
scettici
vediamo se parte ecco perché è
importante bs l'ultimo perché una delle
cose che spingerà la sharing a economy
ovunque la sta già spingendo e già la
ragione per cui airbnb è diventato più
grande hotel del mondo sono i soldi che
ti rimangono in mano alla fine quando la
gente incominciano a farsi veramente i
conti di quanto li costa comprarsi un
automobile cambiare le gomme andare dal
carrozziere assicurarla e quant'altro
e quanto e più efficiente la la mobility
services
vedrete che quando la gente si farà i
conti passeranno tutti in quella
direzione
bene chiudo il nostro viaggio facendovi
vedere una concept realizzato da airbus
e italdesign ter design una società
fondata da giugiaro comprata poi da la
volkswagen e questi due colossi hanno
immaginato la mobilità
nel 2040 e ti assicuro che ci arriveremo
perché tutto quello che ora voi vedete
in questo video e tecnologia oggi
disponibile piattaforme digitali
mobilità elettrica
adesso lo vedrete droni di cui ormai si
legge a piattamente throne i taxi
insomma questo è il futuro è nel 2039
viaggeremo così
[Musica]
e come 3 guardate questo video voi vi
chiederete sì ma questo sarà appannaggio
di pochi
si era la stessa cosa che dicevano
quelli che si compravano la fortina e
1916 era appannaggio di pochi
in realtà nel giro di poco tempo nel
giro di pochi decenni è diventata
appannaggio di tutti
quindi in realtà le tecnologie
abbassando i costi maniera importante e
soprattutto con la sharing economy chi
cambia completamente rispetto alla
prospettiva di potersi comprare una
forti metterà a disposizione questa
esperienza veramente di tutti
[Musica]
bene ci vediamo nel 2039